- Thanks to Skillshare for
keeping Legal Eagle in the air.
Learn to think like a lawyer
for free for two months
by clicking the link in the description.
Turner Tenny, better known
by his Fortnite name of Tfue,
started a firestorm by
accusing his management group,
FaZe Clan of an oppressive labor contract.
What is he complaining about
and is the contract really that bad
or is Tfue just a greedy
gamer who was bitter
about signing an unfavorable contract.
The answer could end up
setting legal precedent
that will determine
the rights of thousands
of professional gamers
all over the country.
(light music)
Hey Legal Eagles, it's time
to think like a lawyer.
Today we are adjudicating the
case of Tfue versus FaZe Clan.
You may know the background here,
hundreds of millions of people
love playing video games.
Their passion for gaming
has led to the creation
of a new industry known as
eSports which allows players
to play competitively for cash prizes.
eSports is a multi-billion
dollar industry.
Professional gamers in 2019
can make millions of dollars,
live in fancy mansions,
fly on private jets
and make plenty of money.
Investors are looking to cash in as well
and are pumping hundreds
of millions of dollars
into the eSports industry
which promises to establish
video game leagues
that will eventually
rival professional sports
in revenue and public attention
and when there's billions
of dollars at stake,
that can only mean one thing, lawyers
which of course leads us to the matter
of Tfue versus FaZe
Clan or is it FaZe Clan.
Capitalization is apparently
hard with these people,
and anyway, if you're watching this video,
you probably already know who Tfue is.
He is a 21 year old gamer
who is currently one
of the top Fortnite players in the world.
Tfue regularly wins Fortnite tournaments,
has made over half a million
dollars in prize money
in just 29 tournaments.
He has his own YouTube
channel and is far and away
the most watched Fortnite
streamer on Twitch.
All of this makes him a star on the rise
in the eSports world.
If you're watching this video,
you probably also know who FaZe Clan is.
It may sound like a mid
90s hip-hop collective,
but FaZe Clan is actually one
of the biggest brands in esports.
FaZe Clan bills itself
as a professional eSports organization.
It has its own or teams with players
who compete in tournaments for Fortnite,
Call of Duty and Rainbow Six.
FaZe Clan also sponsors events,
it has its own Twitch and YouTube streams.
Topping it all off, FaZe Clan reports
to be a lifestyle brand
which sells T-shirts
and hats and other items as well.
In 2018, FaZe Clan sought
to partner with Tfue,
culminating in a contract,
a quote gamer agreement
for Tfue to play for their league.
When Tfue signed the gamer
agreement with FaZe back
in 2018, he wasn't quite
the star that he is now,
but by 2019, Tfue was dominant at Fortnite
and has a growing personal brand
which gave him more opportunities
and endorsements outside
of the FaZe Clan umbrella.
This is probably where
the party's interests
may have started to diverge.
Tfue was unhappy and said
that the gamer agreement
that he signed forced him
to remain with the team
for three years, stuck in with a salary
of just 2,000 dollars per month
and let them keep 50% of most of the fees
and 20% of his prize money.
He also said that the
contract allowed FaZe Clan
to take up to 80% of any brand deals
that were made for
Tfue's personal channels.
That means that if Tfue
signed a deal to run an ad
on his personal YouTube channel,
FaZe Clan would get to
keep most of the money.
The founder of FaZe Clan,
Ricky Banks accused
Tfue of being disloyal.
He said that the company
hadn't taken the 20% cut
of prize money it was entitled
to under the contract.
Banks said that despite
the contract terms,
FaZe Clan hasn't collected any revenue
from Tfue's tournament
earnings, Twitch revenue,
YouTube revenue or any other source.
Banks asserted that his company
had only made 60,000 dollars
on Tfue since the contract was signed.
Tfue characterized the
contract as oppressive
since he's locked in for three years,
an initial six-month term
plus an additional 36 month extension
which FaZe Clan has already exercised
which means that he can't
compete for other teams.
- This is about me in this contract.
This contract that I signed
when I didn't know any better.
I'm an idiot I should have
never signed in the first place.
This three-year contract.
- Tfue then initiated
two legal proceedings
against FaZe Clan.
First he sued FaZe Clan in
court and filed a petition
with the California Labor Commission.
The petition with the California
Labor Commission alleges
that Faze is acting as an
unlicensed talent agency
in violation of California labor laws
which are meant to protect entertainers
from gross exploitation.
The petition asks the
California Labor Commission
to require the state to regulate FaZe Clan
like any other talent agency
and we'll come back to this later.
The second action was a
standard lawsuit filed
in a Superior Court
for Los Angeles County.
In it, Tfue raises seven
claims against FaZe Clan,
a claim or a cause of action in a lawsuit,
are, separate, independent reasons
for why a party asserts they are entitled
to win the lawsuit.
It's normal to put more
than one of those claims
or causes of action in a lawsuit
even if the whole thing
sounds in breach of contract
as Tfue's claims basically do here.
So first, Tfue is asking the court
for what's called a declaratory judgment
about the status of the gamer
agreement that he signed.
A declaratory judgment
is when the court issues
an order determining the
relationship between the parties.
A declaratory judgment is a
binding opinion about the rights
and responsibilities of two parties.
Often you'll see this in
a breach of contract case
where the contract actually
hasn't been breached,
but it will be depending
on the different interpretations
of the two parties.
In that kind of a case,
you go into court asking
for an actual declaration
even before the damages
haven't necessarily arisen.
Tfue says that FaZe Clan
materially breached the agreement
by accepting money from third
parties for sponsorships
of Tfue involving modeling,
jewelry and apparel,
but according to Tfue after
he provided these services,
FaZe Clan did not distribute
any of the money to Tfue
in accordance with the agreement.
Tfue's asking the court
for a declaratory judgment
that the contract was
breached by FaZe Clan
and is now void so he can get
out of any obligations he has
to fulfill the rest of his contract term.
The second claim is a claim
for declaratory judgment
that the clauses in the
gamer agreement which pertain
to exclusivity and matching
rights violates section 16,600
of the California Business
and Professions Code.
California is very
hostile to any agreement
that purports to limit a person's ability
to practice their profession.
The contract has a
six-month non-compete clause
following termination and generally,
non-compete clauses are
illegal in California
except for when you have a non-compete
with an equity partner or like a CEO.
As a result, it's very difficult
for any non-compete agreement
to pass muster under California law,
but there's also an issue in terms of
whether you can just void
the contract provision itself
or whether you have to avoid
the entire contract in general.
Here, section 16,600
states that every contract
by which anyone is
restrained from engaging
in a lawful profession, trade
or business of any kind is
to that extent void.
Under the gamer agreement,
Tfue cannot contract
with another gaming company
without FaZe Clans consent.
Tfue characterizes this and
other sections of the contract
as an illegal restraint on trade
and anti-competitive behavior
that violates section 16,600.
The third claim is for a violation
of California Business and
Professions Code section 17,200
which precludes a person from engaging
in what's called unfair competition.
All California lawyers know Business
and Professions Code section
7203 very, very well.
It's basically a catch-all for
any shady business practices.
It applies to any unlawful, unfair
or fraudulent business act or practice
and unfair, deceptive, untrue
or misleading advertising.
Tfue alleges that FaZe Clan's
business practices embodied
by the gamer agreement have
restrained his business,
caused him financial losses and threatened
to cause other damages.
Tfue wants the court to stop
FaZe Clans business practices
and pay him restitution
for any revenue and profits
that FaZe Clan made from
these business practices.
One of the reasons you
would assert a claim
under Section 17,200 is that it gives you
what are called restitution damages
which are not necessarily
the same as contract damages.
Tfue's fourth cause of action is for money
that FaZe Clan collected
for sponsorship deals
that it did not give to Tfue.
The fifth claim is for quantum merit.
Quantum meruit is a latin term that means
as much as he deserved.
It is an action to recover
the reasonable value
of services rendered by
one party to another.
Tfue alleges that he provided
services to FaZe Clan
and other sponsors and that
those companies benefited
from those services,
but that Tfue did not receive compensation
for the value of those services.
The sixth claim is for
breach of written contracts.
In this claim, Tfue says that in the event
of the Court finds the
gamer agreement is valid
and enforceable, Tfue has done
everything that was required
to do under the agreement
while FaZe Clan has failed
to uphold its end of the bargain.
Tfue is seeking money damages
for breach of contract.
Finally, Tfue seventh cause of action is
for breach of fiduciary duty.
Regardless of whether FaZe Clan
is considered a talent agency,
Tfue claims that it owed
him a fiduciary duty
to act in good faith and in
Tfue's interest at all times.
By refusing a deal to avoid
making another sponsor upset,
the complaint alleges FaZe Clan acted
against Tfue's interest.
So, do any of these claims hold water?
Well, all plaintiffs
write their complaints,
that's the document that starts a lawsuit,
in a way that is favorable to their case
and almost certainly
leaves out any information
that's favorable to the defendant.
So you have to look at these
lawsuits with a grain of salt.
On the bridge of contract
allegations, if true,
they likely do give rise
to a material breach of the contract.
Generally speaking,
when one party has materially
breached the contract,
it lets the other side off the
hook for further performance
and given Tfues newfound fame and success,
that's probably what he cares most about,
to get out of this onerous contract
so he can work with other people.
The section 17,200 claim
is probably a catch-all
in case the breach of
contract claim fails.
The quantum meruit claim
is to recover any funds
that wouldn't already be
covered by the contract
or if the court declares
that the contract is void ab initio,
in other words void from the beginning,
it's a cause of action
that would allow him
to recover what is fair
even if it's not actually
covered by the contract,
but the thrust of the allegations here are
for breach of contract.
Asserting that FaZe Clan
has breached the contract
and therefore Tfue is free
to work with somebody else.
A lot of people have
pointed out how quote,
unfair this contract is as a reason
for why the contract should be voided,
but Tfue isn't really arguing
that the contract is so unfair
as to be legally unenforceable.
He's arguing, as he probably should,
that FaZe Clan breached the contract
and therefore it's void.
There is actually a concept in the law
that voids a contract for unfairness,
it's called when a
contract is unconscionable.
In making this determination,
courts look at both the substantive
aspects of the contract.
Are the terms on their
own unfair to one party,
as well as the procedural aspects
by which the contract was reached.
Did the complaining party
have the time and or resources
to fully understand the contract.
But you have to meet both the procedural
and substantive aspect
of unconscionability
in order for the court to
declare a contract as void.
Tfue's contract doesn't
really fit that definition.
There is no real evidence
of procedural unfairness
like fraud or a contract of adhesion.
Sure, the contract sucks for Tfue
but it probably doesn't fit
the definition of unconscionable.
For example, people
point to the 20, 80 split
of certain fees and winnings,
but that only matters
if Tfue actually won.
Certain gamers might put
great value in the fact
that they get a guaranteed
2,000 dollars per month
and a court isn't likely
to second-guess that.
That's why Tfue's
attorneys don't even bother
really making the argument
that this contract is unconscionable.
Moreover, Tfue is a lot more
famous now than when he signed.
So like a rookie contract
in regular sports,
FaZe Clan would argue
that the contract reflected
the party's positions
when the signer executed the contract
and certainly the uncertainty
of actually working
with Tfue at that stage in his career.
And in addition to a guaranteed salary,
FaZe Clan would argue that
they gave him help and invested
in his future just like
you would in normal sports
when you take on a rookie
performer, but let's talk
about what potential
defenses FaZe Clan might have
to these assertions of breach of contract.
What does FaZe Clan have
to say for its defense.
Well first of all,
FaZe Clan disputes Tfue's characterization
of the gamer agreement,
noting that it has been
in negotiation with Tfue's representatives
to offer him a new and better contract.
FaZe Clan says that its previous
legal team was responsible
for the 80, 20 and 20, 80 split on profits
and after FaZe Clan got
new lawyers last summer,
its new contracts reversed the split
so that the game 80% of all of those deals
and FaZe Clan only gets 20%.
FaZe Clan states that
just like any sports team
or movie company or record company,
its original deal with its
gamers is based on their talent
and their perceived value of that talent
at the time of the contract.
Like any entertainment
company or sports team,
FaZe Clan looks to renegotiate
a deal when the talent starts
to dramatically improve
and this is what the company
alleges it has done with Tfue.
Now this isn't terribly
relevant to Tfue's allegations
that FaZe Clan actually
breached the contract
that they in fact executed.
It's in fact sort of an admission
that their current contract is unfair,
but since Tfue isn't really
arguing unconscionability,
it probably doesn't hurt them
too much to argue the optics
of things and say that they're
offering a new contract.
In recognition of Tfue's
Fortnite abilities,
FaZe Clan says it has offered
him a seven-figure bonus
and some options that give Tfue 100%
of any deals they negotiated for him.
According to FaZe Clan,
Tfue has failed to respond
to any or all of these overtures.
- [FaZe Clan] As early as
September 28th of last year,
we sent the first revised
version of a contract for Tfue.
We sent him a new agreement to his lawyer,
January 24th of this year.
We sent another updated
thought on April third
then again on April 29th.
We gave him so many different options
that had little or even some
of them had no money going
to FaZe Clan and yet we still
couldn't get a deal done
and we come to find
that the reason why is,
he never planned on getting
a deal done with us.
He wanted to start a
competing organization.
- Now whether Tfue has
ignored FaZe Clans overtures
or whether he wants to
start a competing company
as FaZe Clan alleges, probably
won't have much effect
on the lawsuit itself.
The future conduct of the parties
doesn't really have much
bearing on the actual facts
as they exist now and in the past.
FaZe Clan also disputes the notion
that the contracts are predatory.
In its Twitter statement,
the company notes
that over the last several months,
it has encouraged any FaZe
Clan member interested
in hiring an outside
manager or agent to do so,
but FaZe Clan' best strategy
may be to actually lean in
to the draconian terms
of the current contract.
FaZe Clan recognizes the 50, 50 split
and sometimes 20, 80
split in the contract,
it argues that it has
never collected its 80%.
Now, assuming that FaZe
Clan actually upheld its end
of the bargain, FaZe
Clan could be entitled
to that 80% that's actually
written into the contract.
Now that the parties have broken up
and are going their separate ways,
FaZe Clan could go after it's 80%
as written in the contract from Tfue.
After all, what does it have to lose.
Countersuing for 80% would give FaZe Clan
a bargaining chip against Tfue.
Additionally, since FaZe
Clan and Tfue were unlikely
to ever get back together,
FaZe Clan will probably want
to counterclaim for any projected amounts
that Tfue would have made
during the remaining
period of the contract.
- [FaZe Clan] Because we
were having these issues
and because we wanted Turner
to feel that we had his back,
we made the decision to
not collect any money
under the under the old agreement,
nothing from prize pool,
nothing from YouTube,
nothing from anything
except for a couple of
brand deals that accepted
that we only took 20% of
and those deals came from us to him.
- If FaZe Clan upheld its end
of the bargain in the contract
then it would be Tfue who is the one
who was breaching the agreement
by failing to play for FaZe
which would make him liable
for FaZe's expectation damages
during the remaining
years of the contract.
Of course, that is a big if.
In either case, FaZe
Clan will want to show
that it did not breach the contract
while Tfue will argue that
they did breach the contract.
I can't opine on the
likelihood of either situation
because I don't know the underlying facts,
that's what the lawsuit is for.
The crucial question in this litigation is
whether FaZe Clan upheld
its end of the bargain
and gave Tfue everything
he was entitled to
under the contract.
The crucial question is not
whether the contract is unfair to Tfue.
Now, Tfue also filed a petition
with the California Labor Commissioner.
Here, Tfue makes some bold allegations
about FaZe Clans activities.
Tfue says that he was pressured
to drink before he turned 21
and FaZe Clan encouraged
him and other residents
to gamble while on FaZe Clan property.
Tfue says that FaZe Clan
pressured and expected residents
of the FaZe house to
perform dangerous stunts
which resulted in Tfue's permanent injury.
The Labor Commission petition argues
that gamers are entertainers and artists
who must be represented by
licensed talent agencies
under California's Talent Agency Act
which regulates the relationship
between talent agencies and their clients.
For Tfue to be covered
by the Talent Agency Act
among other things, he
has to prove that he falls
under the definition of an
artist under that statute.
To me, the Labor Commission petition seems
like the tail wagging the dog
in this litigation though.
Certainly not an expert
in this particular niche
of California labor and employment law
so feel free to view my
analysis with skepticism here,
but I do know my way around
California litigation
and when you go to the
trouble of filing a lawsuit,
you tend to throw everything
that you have at it.
Some arguments are better than
others and to me, it feels
like the Labor Commission
argument is colorable,
but it's really just there
to back up the main
breach of contract claim.
It's possible that this petition
could have wide-ranging effects
on the professional gamer community
if the Talent Agency Act
is expanding to cover them,
but this seems like a claim
that is probably going to settle
before getting to that
stage and setting a new law,
but we'll see how it unfolds.
Now, instead of watching video games,
have you ever thought about
designing your own video game?
You could learn how by
taking Brandon Wu's class
on making a 2D platformer on Skillshare.
Brandon takes you through all the steps
to building your first
video game with Unity
with no coding required.
You could learn to make the next Fortnite
or if you're more of a fan artist,
you could take Mislav Majdandzic's
master class in pixel art
which will teach you how
to draw sprites right out of Megaman.
Skillshare is an online learning community
that has over 25,000 classes on everything
like lifestyle, design,
technology, business, you name it.
There are almost 2,000
courses on video games alone.
The first 500 Legal Eagles
will get two free months
of Skillshare when you
click on the link below,
plus it really helps out the channel.
The free premium membership
gives you unlimited access
to must know topics so you
can improve your skills
and learn new things.
All free for two months.
Improve yourself and you
could make the video game
that takes over the
entire eSports industry.
So click on the link below,
get two free months of
Skillshare and start learning
to think like a lawyer, today.
It could even help you
become the next Sid Mirror.
So do you agree with my analysis,
do you support Tfue or FaZe Clan.
I think I know
which way you guys are
gonna vote on that one.
Leave your objections in the comments
and check out my other
real law reviews over here
where I analyze pressing issues of the day
like the Muller report and PewDiePie.
So just click on this link
and I'll see you in court in the next one.